Oh kickoff beckons that's right mark
it's the first time that we've had a
definitive date from the Premier League
with regards to the project restart and
they're saying that they hope all being
well pending government approval and
that they will be able to kick the
Premier League back off again after a
three-month break on the 17th of June
now there'd be two fixtures played on
the 17th of June Aston Villa versus
Sheffield United and Manchester City
versus Arsenal though those are four
clubs with games in hand there then be a
full round of fixtures a football
bonanza is how they're trying to sell it
on the 19th and the 20th of June and now
there's nine weeks and sorry then it's
been around 14 weeks by the time the
Premier League resumes since we've seen
live football in this country I think a
lot of opinions of Premier League clubs
have been swayed and in favor of the
Premier League's projects restart by
what they've seen happening in Germany
Germany are now approaching their third
weekend of football fixtures in the
top-flight the Bundesliga since they
returned and it seems to have gone
largely without any major problems
they've been fears about fans perhaps
gathering outside stadiums and possibly
about outbreaks of Kovach 19 within
clubs but in Germany it all seems to
have gone well and that seems to have
melted away some of the objections that
Premier League clubs and players had
against Project risa and another key
thing has been the testing of the
players and players in the Premier
League are tested now twice a week for
Kovac 19 so far there's been three
batches of testing done and I'll just
read you out the numbers here there's
been 2,750 two tests conducted and so
far only 12 positives among the staff
for the non-playing staff and the
players who have been tested so I think
that is another key thing and for many
people this return of the Premier League
will signify
something bigger more of a
turn to normality of course some fans
particularly eager to see the Premier
League return and especially those on
the red red half of Mercy site and with
Liverpool potentially just two games
away from their first top-flight title
for more than 30 years so welcome news
and for some more than others